If Iruma-sama, or by extension, the members of the Abnormal Class, want to get involved again in the future
[music], they'll rush over
immediately from retirement and decapitate them.
Azu-kun only protected us, so
I can tell
you, but I'm satisfied.  It's been a
long time since the three of us got
together, right? It's been a
while since the harvest festival started.  I
tried my best with everyone, didn't I?
This was before we
started playing Maybe it's because I met you two that I feel like the pain has somehow eased It's
thanks to you seeing my face
Hey hey hey
today
[laughter]
Once the festival is over, let's
celebrate together
at my house
[music]
Promise